i want speaking of court cases not going
particularly well i have a very
interesting video of infowars conspiracy
theorist alex jones in connecticut this
is the latest alex jones defamation
trial remember i interviewed the
plaintiff's attorney mark bankston not
long ago and he told us about this
forthcoming case this is absolutely
fantastic alex jones flipped out outside
the courthouse yesterday saying the
judge isn't allowing me to argue that
i'm innocent
now
that's not the way court works and i'm
going to tell you why in a second but
take a listen to what alex jones had to
say this has never before been done in
us history
it's a struggle session right out of
communist china or south africa this is
serious tyranny regardless what you
think about me or how the media is what
i've said over the years i've apologized
for past things i said to her people's
feelings but i wasn't the first person
to question sandy hook and i apologize
years ago they have misrepresented what
i've said and done there's a whole
industry of lawyers around these
families that have sued remington and
won 73 million dollars and won all these
other lawsuits and they simply now are
not just coming for the second amendment
but the first amendment this is a
travesty
of justice and this judge is a tyrant
this judge is ordering me to say that
i'm guilty and to say that i'm a liar
none of that's true i was not wrong
about sandy hook on purpose i questioned
it just like jessie smalling just like
wmds in iraq just like gulf of tonkin
there have been a lot of staged events
in history like wmds in iraq and i
question every major event that we see
and so i'm being put in a possible
position inside of this courthouse where
i'm being ordered to say i'm guilty has
anybody ever heard of someone being
ordered to say they're guilty okay so
alex jones of course is not telling the
truth here's what's going on in this
case
a default judgment was already ordered
last year against alex jones because he
refused to participate in discovery
there was a defamation suit brought
alex jones was ordered to participate in
discovery what that means is you have to
turn over information you have to turn
over documents evidence etc
if you don't do it
it's
similar to just not showing up to court
okay
when you don't do it a default judgment
is found against you you lose by default
it's sort of like you forfeit and that's
what took place
we are now
in the damages space
and jones is trying to argue his
innocence
that is not for this phase that is
supposed to be done in the phase which
he forfeited the right to participate in
because he didn't participate in
discovery so he's saying it's like
communist china
it's like this it's like that it's a t
the judge is a tyrant
these are the rules he didn't
participate in discovery this was the
case in the other defamation suit as
well and now we are in the damages phase
that's how the law works and he claims
to be about law and order
and uh
how very quickly that idea evaporates
but just absolutely pathetic this is
going to be another fascinating trial
huge numbers of people report that cbd
has a calming effect that can help with
anxiety stress insomnia and our sponsor
feels is a premium cbd designed to help
you feel your best delivered right to
your door you just place a few drops of
feels under your tongue cbd can also be
a safe method for relieving minor aches
and pains without side effects
the thing to remember about cbd is that
finding the right dose is important and
feels even has experts on call to help
you with that over the phone if you need
a dose of chill on the go you've got the
feels cbd infused mints and you'll get
fresh breath hard to complain about that
and with a feels monthly membership cbd
is simply a breeze you save money on
every order you can pause or cancel at
any time become a member today and get
50 off your first order with free
shipping when you go to feels.com pacman
and use the code pacman the link is down
below